are you guys ready for the awesomeness
come on that are you ready for the
awesomeness yeah that's one time people
over there are you ready for the
awesomeness keep on the back are you
ready for the awesomeness yeah this is
dude I have like I'm tingling because I
know what you're about to see all right
so we have there's a big announcement
coming hey God you spoiler you got it
for access is doing a first person
shooter it's out of the bag no I want to
I want to introduce will miller who is
take it away will okay thanks everybody
it's a huge crowd for the first time at
the Praxis mega panel we've actually had
to turn people away so consider
yourselves lucky getting in the door
thank you very very much you guys are
awesome we represent a team at for
access that has been quietly working on
something very very special and it's our
great pleasure to show it to you our
biggest fans right now so we have a
little trailer we're going to show you
enjoy since the earliest of
civilizations we have made much progress
but that progress came with a cost our
world has changed
check where five and despite our
advances in both science and technology
we can no longer deny what is clear our
time on earth is ending
so we turn our gaze upward to the stones
an embark on the greatest journey in
human history
a journey into the unknown
to discover a new world
yoo-hoo
the new beginning
for mankind
I think I speak for everyone when I say
holy crap
so on behalf of for access games and on
our team I would like to formally
introduce you to sid meier's
civilization beyond Earth the latest
entry in the civilization franchise a
brand new game charting the future of
mankind as they explore the Stars and
settle an alien planet fans will
recognize familiar gameplay elements in
addition to a number of new features we
will set the game apart from its
historical counterpart and carry on the
traditions of all great for axis
strategy games before we tell you a
little bit more though we'd like to take
this opportunity to introduce ourselves
on the panel here you want to yeah sure
so as you probably haven't met us yet
but we've been at praxis for a while
this is David McDonough and I'm will
Miller where the
David and I are the lead designers on
the project we've been best friends for
a long time and it's an honor to work on
a game like this this is Lena brink who
herds cats all day she's our producer
and Anton stringer who is our lead
systems designer and gameplay designer
we could not make this game without him
uh I had the privilege of having dinner
with these guys last night and meeting
them all personally and I can honestly
tell you that these are people that are
genuinely passionate about this game and
about these kinds of games so I think
you guys are going to really have a
great time today at this panel because
these are people that love what they do
and they're excited about this game as
much as you are so that's really cool
there's this game that I played in the
late 90s that is one of my favorite
games of all time here it comes I
imagine some other people were thinking
about Alpha Centauri when they saw this
trailer
so is this Alpha Centauri to the
elephant in the room I'm sure um so as
many of you were huge fans of Alpha
Centauri you're not going to find any
people that are more of a fan of that
game than we are sitting up here and as
many of you fans know the intellectual
property rights for Alpha Centauri
belong to a different publisher but we
like to think that the heart and soul of
that game lives at Firaxis and for all
of you fans out there that loved Alpha
Centauri this is the game we have made
for you
and for all of the fans who love
civilization games in general we grew up
playing those games just like you did
all 20 years of the Civil legacy from
civil one to civ 5 and his two
expansions and this game is inspired by
the mall it really is an entry that
belongs to stand alongside the entire
city and it represents a new vision for
the idea of seven space for the idea of
the future of mankind based on all of
those titles Alpha Centauri included so
if you're a fan of any of our games we
hope you'll find something to like in
this one so what's the premise guys
what's the starting point how far in the
future are we what's what's going on the
the game picks up about 250 years from
right now you could say it's 250 years
from the end of a typical civilization
game but we actually took modern day
when we were sort of building the the
fiction for the product and went from
there so 250 years from now in about 25
years there's this thing called the
great mistake in any of you guys who are
Dan Simmons fans out there will will get
the reference no one really knows what
the great mistake was but we theorize
that it was some nuclear exchange in the
Asian subcontinent regardless of what it
was though it staged or caused a
humanitarian crisis the likes of which
the world has never known there was a
massive migration of people there were
ecological disasters the nations of the
world were strained to the point of
breaking and there was a dark age over a
period of about two hundred or so years
and the game picks up right as mankind
has hauled itself out of this period and
the nations are back on their feet again
and they have decided given the state of
Earth to to leave to find a new home
elsewhere so this game tells the story
of your expedition the one that you
decide to take to a new world you were
telling me last night you know I think
about the great mistake which I think I
probably made this morning and I'll you
know I'm try to recycle I'm worried
about Earth you know just much as the
next guy and but I think about it as a
scary possible future but I know that
the civilization games are
all very much about hope and aspiration
and you were will you last night you
were telling me how this game is framed
in a very hopeful manner which the way
you explained it last night was amazing
so I'll try to do it I was a couple
drinks in we'll see you we'll see how
this goes well right here sure so I i we
were a little bit vague about the
exposition in this game we sort of hint
at it we drop little hints about what
happens but we never really tell you
exactly what happened to earth and why
he meant humans leave because it's
really the game is really about what
happens when we get there but we've done
a lot of thinking about it and my
personal opinion is that I don't think a
messed up earth would be reason enough
for us to leave I think it would take an
event something something really big to
happen that would galvanize mankind to
leave right before Christmas on in
December of 1968 the Apollo 8 spacecraft
was orbiting the moon and Bill Anders
one of the astronauts aboard happened to
grab a Hasselblad camera with a very
long lens and snapped what has become
the most important photograph ever taken
it's called Earthrise and it shows
planet Earth rising above the the
distance the horizon of the Moon
Kennedy's challenge was to go to the
moon and to come back and during the 60s
we were so fixated on getting there that
when we got there we were surprised to
learn that it wasn't the moon we had
come to see but it was earth and this
photograph changed how we see ourselves
in a single frame Bill Anders captured
every living human on the planet except
the three in the spacecraft obviously
that one photograph and I'm sure all of
you have seen it kick-started the
environmental movement it changed the
way that we feel about us about our
tenuous position in the universe and i
think and i hope to be alive when we see
the next photograph and i think it'll be
probably way lower resolution than bills
a Hasselblad was able to take we'll be
lucky if we get 20 pixels by 20 pixels
but it will be printed on
every magazine and in every newspaper
it'll be enough resolution to see a
globe on a field blackest pitch and on
that you'll see blue water and brown
earth and puffy white clouds but it
won't be earth it'll be somewhere else
and to me that's what it's going to take
it's something like that that makes us
leave it's not that Earth has gone to
hell it's that we want to that we aspire
to so that's that's our take these how
awesome is that
the game we're actually at a point where
we see several of we have found several
of those worlds so a lot of expeditions
are leaving us at the same time rough
time frame and are going out to all
these different planets to colonize them
some are going to the same planets and
they are going all over the galaxy to
find new homes for Humanity in space and
so you'll see different planets you can
go to and every time you play you will
play a different story of a different
expedition that leaves for one certain
planet to make it there to find a new
home there for Humanity yeah I think
that's really an interesting point is
that it's not it's not about humans vs
aliens it's about different factions of
humans all trying to go to that next
place there's a really exciting I think
concept that being said though there is
an alien world that developed and
there's life on that world otherwise we
wouldn't go there because it couldn't
sustain us it might not be intelligent
life so we're not fighting intelligent
aliens will good yeah running into other
human factions but there is life on the
planet and we'll talk a bit more about
that later but it'll play a big role in
the game so where the players start what
do you start with and what's your
situation at the beginning of the game
so the way you start the game is you
actually you start with this idea of the
expedition leaving Earth so you choose
what sponsor what nation sponsor is
going to be kind of funding your
expedition and you see here one of our
sponsors is the pan-asian cooperative
and it's led by down ming and that
carries quick that a certain set of
gameplay bonuses but you also pick what
type of spacecraft you want to leave on
and what you want to put in the cargo
hold and the type of colonists that you
want to bring with you so the choices
that you make even in the game setup
before you start on turn 0 influence the
type of game that you're going to have
and each of them like it tells a
different story every time yeah and some
you guys are mentioning some of them are
with we had the the corporate ah cracy
right the American reclamation corporate
ah cracy yeah
right arc face Google I think it's all
right face Google right by and large
exactly yeah that they're cool one of
the neat things we got to do is
designers a sort of reinvent what earth
looks like after the great mistake and
the sponsors that you see are the best
and brightest from those nations so part
of the cool fiction of the game is
figuring out where they came from and
what their backgrounds are and and down
Ming is one of them but they're there
are many there eight and I don't think
we're gonna talk about all of them today
but you know we can we can cover a few I
can try that I hey you could try so it
mikan smile only concern is is this game
a space is it is it civilization in
space is that it is it just a I can't
think of the word I'm looking for but it
is it just a skin of space on to
civilization uh no it's definitely so
there's no second there's a lot of new
stuff what we like to say is that we we
took the bones of civilization and built
something new on top of it so this game
has the DNA of civilization and as David
mentioned 20 years of its history are
built into this product so you're gonna
feel right at home if you're a civ 5
player you'll know what a city is and
what tiles are and what yields are and
things like that but beyond that treat
it like civ5 at your peril we've had a
lot of fun figuring out how the gameplay
of civ 5 maps to to a space-themed and
it's actually something that Anton can
probably talk better about where he has
worked on gods and kings and brave new
world as a designer so he knows how to
design within the constraints of history
and to design systems that map the cause
of human human history and I know he had
a blast not being constrained and just
going with the systems yeah so I mean
there's their strengths to post
obviously I mean working on both
expansions for civilization 5 it was
really great to be able to kind of
point to history and you know like
Assyria and Portugal we're two sibs I
worked on in brave new world and being
able to go into that rich history and
look at what the characters looked like
look at what their history kind of
suggested for their gameplay and you
guys as players as fans we're able to
kind of latch on and be like oh yeah
like that that really feels like
Portugal that really feels like this and
you have the kind of richness of history
not only just the civilization franchise
but history in general it's kind of draw
from this game on the other hand is free
from that historical context and that
adds a whole new layer of really
exciting opportunities so for example
one of the systems that I've been having
a lot of fun with recently is the
orbital layer so you will be able to
launch satellites and beyond Earth and
they will sit over the gameplay map and
affect the ground below them and in a
civilization game that just doesn't make
sense but with science fiction and win
this awesome world that we've invented
we can really dream up these awesome new
gameplay systems and tell or tell a new
story a new science fiction yeah one of
the things I love most of us sieve is
that I can start you know in the stone
age and move up through the Space Age
and all of those technological
improvements are so satisfying as i go
to start 250 years later where do we go
i mean our is the technology getting
even more and more advanced as you
progress through the game or is there is
it a shorter time frame that you're
dealing with it's shorter than the
civilization insulation covers what
roughly 3,000 4,000 years fictionally
but yeah like where do we go is really i
mean that's the that's the question has
always been in my mind designing the
game as who does humanity grow up to be
at the end of the story and what does it
even mean to win that game I mean
there's no arrival point and so in my
mind the game starts with this big
turning point in the history of human
affairs you know we had to leave our
home the only home we've ever known and
find a new world so you play from that
point until the next great turning point
in human history and you sort of decide
what that is whoever wins a game is the
one who has effectively decided what the
next era of humanity is but also they
decide what it even means to be human at
that point what is the definition of
humanity here in the future because even
right now even in our
modern world she liked that definition
is changing really quickly it's really
already very complicated and it's moving
at a breakneck pace in all directions
and I think that's really well
represented in the technology system so
the single biggest probably systemic
change in this game from civ 5 is the
technology as a web it's not a tree and
you start in the middle surrounded by
technologies that are relatively
recognizable you know physics
engineering ballistics genetic
modification and so on and genetics
let's say you understand what genes are
right just normal stuff you know good
stuff with just some of David's house
and you you grow out into any of the
technological frontiers and the web
represents all of them and they're you
know the web interlinks you can move
laterally you can sort of explore the
technology is much more explorative much
more reactive to where you find of kind
of find technologies that fit the
situation that you're that you're in the
you know that the situation on the
planet the neighbors around you the
particular needs of your colonists etc
you get the technologies that match what
what your goals are and by the end of
the game you have maybe seventy percent
of the text and they represent they
effectively represent the story of who
you are and the story of your neighbors
is something different they have a
different collection of technologies and
they could be wildly divergent by the
end of the game so that you have armies
of like semi-sentient robotic soldiers
fighting armies of like genetically
modified alien life-forms and that's
that's the battlefield and the two of
you have these radically competing
visions for what humanity is and then
you'll start the game over and your
planet will be different your facts
you'll be different everything will be
different you'll make a different set of
selections and tell a different story a
few humanity is but it all comes down to
the technology tree like those represent
the kind of ideas you grasping ideas and
adding them to the definition of
humankind so that by the end of the game
and when you make that leap it's a
remember riot of the Carl Sagan quote
they won't be us but someone very like
us who you will be at the end of this
game will not be who you are now it'll
be not recognizable really to any
modern-day human and that's the fun of
the game is kind of figuring
who that is over the course bit and that
is actually something sorry no go ahead
that is something that we talked earlier
about how the gameplay that there's so
many possibilities because it's the
future and the designers were free to
just come up with new systems this what
David just described was something that
you can probably imagine the artists had
a blast with this as well because they
were just able to create a world so
you're seeing some slides on the side
and you're seeing this world that
they've created with strange resources
we saw flowed stone earlier now we're
seeing an alien one of the avian
wildlife that inhabits the planet when
you land there and that will act
aggressive or less aggressive depending
on your actions but the our team as
opposed to as civilized historic
civilization games but there's obviously
a lot of reference that we need to take
into account to make the units
recognizable here they had to or hadn't
had the opportunity i should say because
they were really enthusiastic about just
creating those those futures of humanity
because depending on if you go a robot a
crude or if you go into gene
modifications your soldiers will
obviously look different your army will
look different depending on which with
which path you choose to take with your
civilization so that was a huge yeah the
our team had lost let me just say like I
love the idea of a whole bunch of
cubicles at Firaxis with garbage cans
full of historical text books oh yeah
like we don't need these anymore it was
grown up yes hold on we love all his
sadness in his too so we had to really
pinch ourselves to remind ourselves is
this really going in a civilization game
we're really gonna put this in a sieve
game and it is awesome you know like the
the art guys had a lot of fun and as
Dave mentioned and Elena mentioned this
idea of who we are and what we are at
the end of the game is fundamental not
just to the to the fiction of the
product but also the mechanics of the
game itself this choice so as you
negotiate through as you navigate
through this techweb you start to
accumulate levels in one of three are
all of
three affinities which we have here the
technology affinities harmony purity and
supremacy and these three affinities
represent the three posthuman ideas that
we have that we thought were the most
evocative so do you want to yeah I mean
affinities as a new idea of the game I
would say it's somewhere in between an
ideology and a religion or philosophy it
effectively represents an attitude about
what humanity ought to be in the future
but also how humanity is going to deal
with the challenges of their their new
existence the fact that they left Earth
and they have nothing and they're on a
planet that they did not evolve to live
on and so starting from the from the
left harmony represents you examining
the new ecosystem that you're on and
figuring out how not how you can like
you know survive on as a human but
really how you change the very genes and
DNA and the organism of a human to be
indigenous to this world to be like a
human from this planet so you really
like take all your eggs and put it like
in the planet basket you invest heavily
in becoming a person or a thing that
belongs on this world it lives in
symbiosis with its ecosystem you know
that effectively won't repeat repeat any
environmental missteps that we made on
our planet and that involves a lot of
things like genetic modification alien
Sciences you know geophysics and ecology
and so on and you gain a lot of sort of
synergy with the alien life with alien
floor and fauna to the point where you
eventually can use the alien creatures
in your armies or breed entirely new
creations based on their genes your past
experience a good so right again he's
having a lot of all right yes so um so
that's that's just one way that we could
end up at the end of this story
supremacy is very much kind of the
opposite it says humanity managed to get
off their planet they've survived
because of their technology because of
the tools that were able to build and
the machines the machines or what saved
us so we're going to double down on that
idea and really invest heavily in things
like advanced robotics bionics
cybernetics nanotechnology and then
artificial intelligence to the point of
semi artificial sentience synthetic
thoughts
even to the point of perhaps replacing
all are part of our human of our organic
existence with machine existence the
idea being that if we can sort of live
in this sort of pure resilient machine
state we can survive anything the
humanity was resilient can any any
future Cataclysm will be able to handle
and so that's obviously you know I said
in the end the robotics a sort of Tron
level direction so those are the guys
will have the the robot soldiers until
or the uploaded consciousness and then
purity is probably the most sort of
idiosyncratic the most interesting in my
mind they represent a rejection of both
ideas and the belief that wherever
humanity goes in the universe it is
their duty they're calling to remain
essentially human that it like that if
we lose who we were that we lose who we
are like the definition must must
persist and so they don't try to change
themselves to fit the planet they don't
try to make themselves into robots they
try to keep themselves purely human the
in fact invest in stripping out a lot of
the flaws like genetic diseases and
things that are in the human genome and
making it an ideal human and then at the
same time making the planet into a new
earth like making the environment that
they live an ideal for Humanity not the
other way around so this is things like
really heavy-duty terraforming a lot of
like a planetary engineering and
extremely heavy munitions yes right and
you can you can sort of appreciate that
if the three at the three of these a
symphony tease coexisted on the same
planet and shared borders they wouldn't
get along no and so that's why I
described it as if like whoever is
whoever wins the game is the one who
decides which one of those definitions
is right and who gets to decide where we
go next so they all they all have their
own victory conditions so in replacement
of technological victory you might be
used to from sieve there's affinity
victories and you know to achieve the
ultimate end of a devotion to one of the
affinities is to win the game and
there's two other ways there's kill
everybody that's always an option
and then the last one which which which
we enjoy a lot is um it's called contact
and it it essentially means that you
become the first human beings who will
act as an ambassador to another sentient
alien race they don't live on the planet
you find things you know evidence of
them eventually you can sort of like
find out where they are based on bits
and pieces you can piece together from
the planet that you land on but to like
make contact make first contact is
another victory condition and that's
sort of universal anybody from any
affinity and when that it's the young
the diplomatic victory in a way while we
still see the slide um what you see here
is also the unit upgrade system so we
have unit customization and beyond Earth
and depending which affinity you pick
you get different upgrades available to
you at certain affinity levels and what
you see here is the first and second
level which are still shared humanity
hasn't developed far enough into any
affinity to make it distinguishable
visually but at the third step it starts
to branch out and here the player has
embraced purity so what they've said
about like heavy armor and just like
bring all the strength you happen yeah
last everybody away that's what you see
here yeah so the like will mentioned
purity or like Dave mentioned i should
say lots of heavy munitions so these
affinities are not just philosophies
reflective on the tech web there are
also gameplay systems like we've been
talking about and one of the ways that
that's reflective is likely to mention
the unit upgrades will change depending
on what affinity you go for so the
purity upgrades here purity has a
certain sort of tactical flavor to it so
when you have a purity army in the field
it behaves a certain way and its
upgrades kind of have a certain profile
and it has it's it's basically about raw
strength and about hovering above the
ground and not having to worry about the
torrian and just bringing as much
firepower as you can harmony is about
using the land around you and healing
and using kind of hostile alien
life-forms and hostile terrain to your
an advantage and supremacy is about sort
of tactical
geometry and kind of organizing your
units to support each other and getting
a lot of bonuses for that all this
sounds incredibly awesome I'm geeking
out like crazy and I like how just
calmly you guys are saying like you have
a cybernetic army facing against a I'm
like that's the coolest thing ever how
are you not doing backflips the other
cool thing that I heard is that there
will be a quest system in this game gets
talked about that a little bit that's
right what would a science-fiction game
be without really cool sci-fi narrative
right civilization has always been one
of the best games for generative story
for procedural narrative when you look
on the fan forums or you know you talk
to civ players they always tell you the
stories of their games I mean that's one
of the coolest things you can go on
reddit and see these incredible stories
that the guy that what been playing civ
to for ten years or something I mean
this stuff is just incredible and we see
that at praxis every day and we love
that and we want to build systems in our
games that really underscore this
wonderful property of our products and
the quest system is one of those things
it's a an interesting addition to
civilization because it's it's sort of
non deterministic you get quests
depending on the game state but they're
kind of random so different ones will
show up at different times in different
playthroughs they give different rewards
so you can't really game them as much as
you might another mechanic and
civilization but they look right but we
try to deliver this this fiction in
these chunks that that kind of I think
the best analogy is the the way that
magic the gathering does it so Matt
every every magic card has this little
blurb at the bottom that kind of gives
you this little window into what's going
on in in the world of magic the
gathering we sort of took the same
approach with our fiction how we deliver
the fiction but the the mechanical
purpose of this system is to pull you
through the new the new systems in the
game to provide you with these things to
do these goals to do that could give you
an edge
over your over your competitors and to
tell the story of the world and it's a
really neat addition to the game i
really like it civilization has been
around since nineteen ninety one which
is 23 years crazy wow it has sold more
than 21 million copies what why this
direction for civ well what was the
inspiration to go this way well I think
ever since alpha centauri everyone's
wanted us to go back here and we have
wanted to it's been a dream of the
studio for the 16 years or so since that
game the first game because it's just
too good an opportunity to pass up i
mean the reaction in the room after the
trailer saw all the evidence you need
that civilization plus sci-fi is a very
compelling combination and it was really
like in this case it was really just
we've found a moment we finally had the
moment where the right team the right
timing with the other products and the
right enthusiasm like will and i have
been sort of dreaming about making a
space game for years long before now and
finally just finally emerged and once
that it's that opportunity finally
walked in the doors of for access we
were not gonna not going to pass it up
well are you guys collaborating with the
man himself Sid Meier is a man yes so
Sid Meier is the creative director of
our studio his his name is on the top of
our game and it is a very much a stamp
of quality for us we this is a sid
meier's civilization product so you know
it's going to be good Sid is really
great to work with he's one of the most
humble people and that I've ever met in
this business and he's also one of the
most productive I mean the guy is
impulsive about making games he writes
the games himself he's very old school
we learn a lot from him and the way that
we approach games trickles down it's
actually institutionalized at our studio
we have a like like I said SIDS the
creative director we have a director of
gameplay development but game designers
like David and Anton and I our boss is
actually our engineering lead so we we
are programmers first
that's how Sid works and that and he has
cultivated this culture at for access of
designer programmers of focusing on
rapid iteration and you know on design
through prototype and we take that very
very seriously and he's also you know an
open door kind of guy so we've talked to
him all the time about about this game
and how we can make it better and he's
been a huge help yeah we if you ever
hear I'm ever anyone heard Jake tell
answer this very question when talking
about XCOM how he has like the the
mythical green chair that'll go in and
weep instance office when when he's
stuck on some problem it's not actually
mythical it's really there it's very
comfortable and it's a little moist from
all the tears there yeah there's room
for the both of us in it though it's uh
i mean yeah likes it is just he's just
down the hall in his own office all the
time he's a very very present mentor to
everyone at the company not just the
designers and I mean the legacy of civ
is his legacy it is his imprimatur on
everything that we do it's it wouldn't
this these games would not really be
made without the ground that he's laid
for them and still does I think that
does it this has been awesome you guys
it's so inspiring to have these guys
here yeah
you
you